[Applaudissements]
côté couleurs les chéris du bois il faut
pas beaucoup si magnifique superbe
allez on commence avec un classique
le missionnaire et devoir refaire le
missionnaire le missionnaire alesi a
beau s allonge moi un cauchemar et mais
dans l'autre sens non sont immenses et
mettez les coutures est ainsi que je me
réfère ici là et là voilà tout
simplement voilà voilà c'est bien pas
mal merci voilà il arrive pas on vous un
peu quand même facile à 10 pouces un peu
quand même
on y va en deuxième on va faire la
position il ya dix versions de faire la
missionnaire nature je connais trop bien
mach'allah l'andromaque l'andromaque
alors l'autre doc gynéco tut allonge
alors vas-y vas-y assas après la sas et
melilla vitesse réelle a même rendu dans
les films rocco requête sa sociaux c'est
compliqué pour les gens qui sont vides
disons qu'il se retient pas très bien
formés qui décide c'est bien c'est bien
c'est très bien le ferry de quoi le
phénix l'impact au micro
voilà où là ça se complique après un
hiver normal
ah oui le phénix allait bien alors on va
te ce sera la dernière à sciacca
attention à la une à la deux cas les
fonds seront pas au label coach n'a pas
accouché à coucher un peu gratuit
[Rires]
louis j'adore les lavandes et y aller ba
ba rester comme ça j'ai quoi rester
comme ça allait je voudrais remercier
rocco siffredi d'abord être avec nous
merci